love this guy i've known him for a
quarter century uh i love getting to
know him when i was mostly a baseball
guy back at the worldwide leader in
sports his voice is on in my house more
than anybody else's on the television
set he's the voice of the new york
yankees which is a dream job for anybody
who grew up uh in the new york city area
and on top of it he's added one of the
most listened to sports talk radio shows
in the country uh the host of the
michael k show michael k here on the
program how are you michael
i'm great rich how you doing well i
don't follow baseball anymore michael uh
to be honest with you
that was rough
okay
what do you think the aftermath is
what's going on in the yankee front
offices today do you think michael k
i think they've got some tough decisions
to make and there's several ways that
they could go rich you know do they do
they sacrifice
boon
to the baseball fan gods
uh to give them something if they did
that
i think it would be disingenuous he is
doing the bidding of the front office
there are scripts that are written that
he of course can deviate from somewhat
but it's essentially from up top
the way this game is played by the
yankees so if they get rid of boone and
that's what yankee fans seem to want
when they call into my show
if you get boone 2.0
what difference does it make boone's a
great guy he represents the organization
very well i think if they go with
something different
like a bocce or a social or or showalter
then i think that indicates a seismic
change because there's no way any of
those three guys
take that job
and are still allowing the front office
to be as
um influential on their decisions i
think they want information those guys
but they're gonna make the final
decision so
uh i think that that's what that the
desire is not it's not brian that's
going to decide it's going to be hal
steinbrenner and his family you know do
is it time to change you know they've
won one title in 20 years so i'm not
quite sure what's going down because i
think that brian cashman thinks that
aaron boone does a great job
uh and you know for what brian watson
manager aaron is doing exactly what he's
supposed to do
so maybe the information that aaron's
getting isn't as good that's something
to consider well i mean what's not as
good is that starting pitching i mean
unless you want to go the way of the
rays the openers and then get the the
the 10 guys who throw 100 miles an hour
to give you an inning and anything you
know two innings a night i mean uh uh
and and then a team that strikes out way
too much
i mean kind of that's what we saw last
night um stanton came alive and judge
and stanton back to back are just
incredible i mean when they mash that's
the the two best guys you can put next
to the uh
in a lineup in major league baseball but
it's just you know uh 11 strikeouts no
walks that's what happened last night
fewer six or fewer hits like the the
last time that happened from what i saw
was 2015. 11 walks and no 11 strikeouts
and no walks in the postseason games
only happened twice before in the
history of the new york yankees i mean
what about the roster makeup here uh
michael
i i think the roster at the beginning of
the year was terrible was terribly
conceived all right-handed uh they they
did a mid-season correction with gallow
and with rizzo and i believe that that
helped but
if you looked at last night's lineup
rich
that's that's a that's a
non-representative line of proposed
season game
after stanton from the fourth batter to
the ninth batter they were one for 20
and the one was an infield hit right
and your cleanup hitter
just can't do it so
again the yankees like home runs and
they don't seem to mind strikeouts as
long as they come with walks you know
the whole three true outcome nonsense
right but i gotta tell you this
if they
roll it back and do it again and bring
this crew back it'll be the same ending
because what you've got in that lineup
now is 200 strikeouts 200 strikeouts 200
strikeouts and if you start gary 200
strikeouts it's too many strikeouts and
i think
you know they're very you know they're
very set in their ways and they believe
in the decisions they make but i don't
think gallows the answer i don't i just
i i don't think he's the answer he's
going to strike out in the full season
230 times and i know he's going to walk
120 to me that's not good enough the guy
hit 160. so i think they've got if you
look at this lineup right now rich
who's the sure thing coming back who's
the sure thing that you say that guy's
great that guy's great it's judge and
stanton
and maybe maybe maybe you say
laboratories is our second baseman and
maybe you say or shella is your third
baseman who else is the sure thing
they've got to get a shortstop they
probably have to get another catcher
they've got to solve what they're going
to do at first base do you bring back
rizzo a lot of money is aaron hicks the
answer in in center field
these are tough questions i'm not quite
sure what they're going to do do they do
you really want to roll back with gallo
and if they traded gala would that be
admitting a mistake they've got some
tough calls to make this is not going to
be an easy off season for them i would
agree with you michael uh just to answer
your questions there uh i would trade
gallow that's what i would do uh i would
keep rizzo i don't know
again you're you're closer to the team
um
he strikes me he's got like o'neil in
them i don't know if they're if they do
have the same personality but he's just
got this way about him this leadership
quality about him this left-handed
hitting
quality about him i i love him i i i
think he should be in pinstripes forever
i know he wasn't nearly as effective as
he was in the first two three weeks of
the season
i just think you know uh him him and and
judge and stanton
um you know obviously the machine when
he comes back healthy i i like that that
i i don't know i kind of dig that what
do you think
what do you think no i think they would
like yellow back at the that gallow
they'd like rizzo back at the the right
numbers right because you know they they
might have to talk about this big money
extension with judge who proved all of
his doubters wrong without staying
healthy he was unbelievable
um
if if it's the right price i think they
would take them back remember i don't
think they want to get into a five or
six year deal with a 31 year old you see
how that worked out with with le mayo
and you know you mentioned the mayo as
well
um he had a really bad year i mean you
watch every game he did not play well
that's true but just the fact that he
was not that lineup last night was
really big of course because if you put
him at the top of the lineup all of a
sudden
the flotsam and the jetson after the
third spot it gets longer you could put
rizzo then fifth and gallow six and it
just becomes a different lineup even
with the specter of a diminished lemayo
at the top so by having the to il him
because of the hip that or not the hip
the sports hernia that that played a big
role in that weak lineup that they ran
out there yesterday and then of course
michael k here on the rich eisen show uh
what would george m steinbrenner iii say
about the guy he gave 300 million
dollars to go in just two innings in
fenway park
in the do or die all or nothing game
against the red sox what what about
garrett cole moving forward here well
michael you know we we had a two-hour
post game on yes last night and uh i
think this guy's gonna wear this for a
long time but
maybe you would agree with me on this
i'd go to war with that dude
he didn't choke he's pissing big gains
before and pitch very very well
he's got great stuff he had a really
good year he's probably going to finish
second and cy young this is no hack this
is a guy who had a bad game
and uh again i think the yankees are
very fortunate to have him for the next
seven years and i think you know he's
going to pitch a lot of big games for
them he's going to win more than he's
going to lose
and it was one of those things i think
that aaron boone lifted him at the right
time but if that's not that game i pray
he probably gives him six innings of
three-run baseball i think he would have
found it and and found a way i also
think that he was probably
affected quite a bit by the sticky stuff
ban uh because you know he had probably
been learning the pits that way for the
last two or three years all of a sudden
was taken away because before they came
down with the crackdown rich
first two months of the season he was
unhittable so i think he's gonna have to
solve that issue but again that's the
guy i'd go to war with i think he he
wears everything on his sleeve he's a
leader in that room uh the players
respect him he gives it his all never
makes excuses he would not even make any
excuse about the hamstring yesterday
there seemed to be something bothering
him you know showalter who we did the
post game show on yes with yesterday he
thought that there was something up that
he just didn't look like he felt right
but he's not gonna he's not gonna make
excuses he's not that guy but in a very
very big game he didn't pitch well but
remember last year he pitched two pretty
big games and he pitched really really
well so again i don't think he was a
matter of choking i think it was a
matter of sometimes you're just not
going to be great hey man great the game
he pitched this year michael in houston
uh was incredible unreal and the yankees
needed it in the worst way and he like
basically stared at aaron boone like
you're not taking me i don't care what
you're doing or what cashman told you
before the game or like like you're not
taking me out and that's the guy that we
needed to see last night that's the guy
you need to see
he just didn't have it i agree
i agree and i'm just wondering if you
know obviously you're talking about
injuries and the sticky stuff and all
that but after a while when you're the
only guy that you can rely on as the ace
like i i wonder if if that if that adds
up because again kluber montgomery ty
own
i mean you know pettit we're we're not
we're not seeing pettit we're not seeing
key you know uh you know cone wells not
walking through the door like those guys
are not walking through the door and uh
i guess just to put a fine point on it
is is what does happen what do you think
needs to happen in the next few months
because the yankees are like i'm seeing
the dodgers you know and the dodgers
they're nervous people here in los
angeles tonight because they just saw
what happened to the yankees and the
yankees didn't win 100 million games
this year but they got scherzer aureus i
mean bueller i mean my gosh the yankees
would get steamrolled by something like
that and the raise they don't even have
the uh starters they got the openers it
doesn't matter for them so what do you
think needs to happen here michael i i
think there has to be a little bit of a
change in in
what they do organizationally i am all
in on analytics i understand the value
of it but what i would like to see is
more of a model
of what the red sox do
where they give core all this
information and they let him do his
thing
and i think that that's the healthy way
to do this but you know there are teams
that are very successful
that do it the way the yankees would
tampa bay is rigidly analytic
i mean kevin cash is a good manager but
he is executing the script that he's
handed down so either you change the way
you do business rich
or you change the people that are doing
the analytics because right now uh the
anchors in the american league east the
rays aren't going anywhere
the red sox by the way this was a reload
season they were not supposed to be in
the playoffs they're gonna get better
because now they'll go over the luxury
threshold and they've got a really good
gm in bloom
and then you saw with the uh the toronto
blue jays as a team that no one wanted
to play in the postseason so you know
and boone said you know people catching
up with us well you know what maybe
you're falling back just a little bit
and they've got to get better they've
got i think they've got to get more
athletic
um i think they're too dependent on home
runs and i realize home runs win because
look tampa bay hits a load of home runs
but you know what the difference is rich
they don't strike out that they don't
they get on base they all run they all
field and then
you know i mean my god that that hit
that uh that rizzo set up a judge for
the game-winner to put them in you know
boston last night almost was caught by
the second baseman out in short right
field i mean and then gallow you know
bunted his way on because there were
four outfielders i mean i i i don't know
i just don't that just drives well
it's funny because what people were
saying on my show last friday well i
mean the yankees will win these three
games because the rays you know they
have nothing to play no you don't get it
no it's a 28-man roster every single one
of their guys has a purpose and knows
how to play the game the right way
they can't tank they're unable to tank
because anybody they put in that lineup
is going to do the job to the best of
their ability that's a nasty team
and they all accept their roles they're
not highly paid they know exactly what
they're doing with a 60 million dollar
payroll they have steamrolled most of
the american league i agree before i let
you go michael k what is said on the
michael k show on espn new york when the
subject matter of kyrie irving comes
back i mean in in the the brooklyn nets
have
as great a roster as anybody in this
league i know what they're doing here in
los angeles and the defending champs are
still milwaukee in the nba season that's
about to start but you know the report
by your colleagues on the espn
television side michael um well jin
windhorst saying that the nets are
really going to prepare to have kyrie
for half a year or they're going to
trade him but what it what is happening
there in brooklyn in the way the fans
are handling all that well
i mean the funny part rich is that it's
still a nick town right and whenever we
talk next you get some
attraction but not that many people are
are over overly interested uh listen i'm
not gonna tell a guy to get a vaccine i
believe in the vaccine obviously you do
as well i know your story
um but i think that the nba through then
that's a life point i really did uh by
coming out and saying that if you don't
play you're not gonna get paid the nets
would never do that the nets are run by
kevin durant kyrie irving
so if they had done that you you would
just take off kevin durant and you can't
do that uh the nets by acquiring those
three guys have made themselves great
but they've also taken a lot of the
power out of the front office hands now
whether you think that's right or wrong
kyrie is a different bird he's one of
the greatest players you'll ever see but
i could see this guy
putting his foot down and say i don't
care if i lose 20 million dollars i'm
not taking the vaccine and i think that
could really submarine what this team is
trying to do to have this guy not play
on the road not play uh the couple games
at madison square garden not play the
one game in san francisco it'll be a
distraction a constant distraction he's
not even able to practice with the team
rich because he's not allowed into the
arena or the practice facility in
brooklyn so i think this is a terrible
terrible uh thing for the nets and i
don't know how they're gonna get out
from under it i don't think he could
trade him because i don't think that uh
kevin would allow it or kyrie would want
it i i don't know and then you know well
kyrie said that you know through back
channels that he would retire
because because even if even if let's
just say
you're you know the the net say we'll do
you know any kyrie is better than than
no kyrie
i mean how do you like play one way at
home in one way on the road you know
what i mean like and how do you practice
how do you get anything together gelling
as a team are they that good that they
could actually win a championship like
that i mean i don't know
you know i believe it's a nightmare
scenario this is not what they need
because kyrie in his own way is always
going to be a little bit of a
distraction because he's you know he's a
different birdie he operates on a
different wavelength than most of us and
maybe smarter than all of us i don't
know but once you affect what happens on
the floor as you said you can play two
different styles have two different
offensive sets to play with him there
with him not there and he's such an
important part of what they do now you
know a team should be able to win a
championship with durant and harden but
then
plugging in and plug taking out a great
player out of the mix it's got to be
it's got to be a detriment to them for
their ultimate goal
michael great season with the yankees
again uh you know i just love listening
to you and the rest of the crew they're
so good really it's a terrific broadcast
and i'll say this you know i think
o'neil is as good as anybody on
television i think he's incredible
and obviously i'm bisexual
i don't know if you agree with me i i
don't know if there's a better analyst
on in all sports even nationally than
david cohen cohn is great too i mean yes
i i i shouldn't leave i know i'd put it
in a position of of leaving somebody
else no the combination i think really
works i mean i'm probably the worst one
of the three
those two are great together stop it
stop it you know but you you know you do
you know the number of people who um
trolled on me on twitter including one
of my colleagues who's not here today in
chris brockman uh using the words sia at
me
um i just think you should know that um
you know that your words are being
thrown back at me
uh and it's not funny you know what i
always think and it's really a sad sad
thing for me rich what is it michael
when i die
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
oh my god the back page of the post
michael k in the meantime be well love
you brother take care of yourself love
you back be good ladies and gentlemen
michael k right here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here